I'm really annoyed that I couldn't think
of an appropriately meta joke told in
this language so news broke earlier
today that there is going to be a
Deadpool animated series being produced
by Donald Glover and it's going to be
appearing on FXX which is right now the
current home of Archer so that should be
nothing but good news this is going on a
network that has no problem with more
adult-oriented animation which means
they're not going to shy away from the
audience that they cultivated with the
movie um and Donald Glover has shown
himself in the past to be a very much a
comic book geek and he he is going to
obviously you know have a reverence for
this character so it's going to be right
up there on screen so why do I not think
this is a very good idea well it's kind
of weird and much like when I saw say
the Blade Runner 2049 trailer and was
like something's not right i had to
reverse engineer to try and figure out
why when i read that news that wasn't
going yeah because that logically should
have been my reaction i'm always
doubting the benefits of animation i
have a sub series called animation
junkie
I love animation and yet I somehow I
think that this is the wrong fit for
this property and I'm going to do my
best to try and explain basically the
short version and I'll expand on this
the short version is that I think
Deadpool will work best the more in
contrast to the world he's in the
character is that's why he works very
well on the comic book page where there
is granted some very ridiculous stuff
going on but it's all being taken so
seriously and you know that whole medium
takes himself so seriously that him
being as a reverend as Diaz is in
contrast to that that's where you get a
lot of the humor from I mean you know
there's the just the randomness of it
too but that's at the heart of the humor
he is the wacky guy in the straight
world and that's very much the case with
the movie as well like everything going
on around with him pretty Poe phase
pretty straightforward he's the one
who's not
so the problem with putting him in a
cartoon is that inherently an animated
world is not as grounded he is not going
to stand out as much in contrast to this
animated setting I mean he he is a
living cartoon and you know that's not
like in a Roger Rabbit sense but I mean
like he is so cartoonish in his behavior
everything else that in that live-action
movie it stands out all the more and it
also stands out and the comic looks for
a similar reason even though visually it
also matches the thing about animation
particularly American animation which is
what this is going to be it's a little
bit different in Japan with in the
history of anime and everything else but
when American animation there just isn't
the same sort of standard of what
reality is so when you insert a wacky
character into a car into a literal
cartoon world it doesn't have that same
contrast where it feels as fun or it
feels as fresh and again to try and
explain why it still works in the comics
even though that is hand-drawn it's
because the comic books as had already
for decades set a standard of we take
this seriously I mean comics hadn't
always been serious but certainly since
the 80s that had been the center we take
this super serious so when this guy was
prepared to tweak the nose of all these
other characters who were taking
themselves so serious in this medium
that took a social series it worked
cartoons as a medium again particularly
American cartoons don't take themselves
very serious so there isn't that baked
in sort of subvert there isn't a baked
in seriousness to the medium that he's
able to subvert so it all has to exist
completely within the world of the
cartoon itself and I'm not saying it
can't do that I'm not saying they can't
create a more serious you know for lack
of a better comparison you know spawn
the animated series kind of world to
draw Deadpool in and there can be some
fun hat in that but that because
animation just doesn't have the inherit
Poe faces of comic books or live-action
film that the contrast isn't it severe
and I feel it's just going to lessen the
character event and just sort of firm
this up for myself I went
and I checked out some of the animated
gif pool stuff that is out there I mean
official stuff I'm not talking fan work
but there was there was an animated
special film DVD thing a Wolverine
versus Hulk that Deadpool appeared it
and that was pretty good but as good as
it was going to be Nolan North poison
for that that worked pretty well um but
you know he was a side character on that
so a little hard to get a gauge on he
also appeared an ultimate spider-man a
voice by Wilfried oh and while he was in
the lane like really grating lis
irritating oh oh that that that was bad
that hurt so and that was then that was
the case where they really leaned into
the excessive cartoonish sense it was
likely trying to make him a Looney Tunes
character and boy it hurt I mean part of
it was just the the pitch on the vocal
performances pour into my ear was not
good um and then you know I also checked
out some of the stuff from the Deadpool
video game and again it's not it's not
bad but there's something about how a
reverend he is in a clinical real-world
setting that I think made it work but I
would argue even better than he does on
the comic book page there's something
about somebody that ridiculous existing
in what seems to be the real world that
to me actually elevates it the the base
level impact of just how ridiculous he
is gets elevated even beyond his comic
book origins so to bring it back to
animation where just the standard of you
know what what is real and what a series
is completely different from live action
or even comic books I just don't I think
it's going to get old and I think it's
going to get old a lot quicker than they
expect it to um yes I mean obviously
look there can be very funny animations
there can be very funny animation names
at adults I mean FX is own Archer IV
zoom proven I love Archer but I think to
myself what I tuned in week after week
to watch him bounce around like Daffy
Duck and that's not me
presuming mood on the thing but the
Deadpool's appeal is how wacky he is and
you put him in a literal cartoon in the
Looney Tunes comparison just it gets all
the stronger now you know I suppose they
give me more why couldn't it be more in
line with how he appeared in in
Wolverine versus Hulk the thing is
though that was a more toned down
version of the character in terms of
embracing the wackiness the fourth wall
breaking all that was gone he just kind
of you just kind of cracked wise now and
then at this point I think the
expectation has been set by the movie
that they're not going to settle for
just that they're going to lean into it
at least as hard as the movie leaned
into it if not more because of animation
you can get away with more and again I
think that's just going to keep in the
character a bit and we're just going to
end up with something closer to his
appearance in ultimate spider-man which
again just whole boy and the thing is
even just beyond the contrast of him
clashing with how serious comic books
are or how serious we expect you know a
real-world set superhero film to be a
lot of the base of his humor aside from
that contrast is just being wacky and
random and cartoon shows right now are
awash in wacky random that's basically
the entirety of Cartoon Network's output
at this point whether it's part of Adult
Swim or for kids that's kind of the
bread and butter of modern animation
right now is is wacky random humor and I
don't know if Deadpool has got to stand
out the way he would have I don't know
maybe ten years ago or so now they just
be saying this is a horrible idea it
can't work no I think it is possible it
could still work but I think there's a
lot stacked against it and until I start
to see footage come out of this it's
something I am going to be really
skeptical of because I think there's a
lot of baggage in terms of what American
animation what people are used to seeing
from American animation that is going to
work against it and I think just the
inherent nature of the character and
where he plays best I think we're going
to find it animation might not be it
certainly not on any kind of an ongoing
long term
so um I'll be curious I'm trying to be
hopeful my opinion on Donald lovers and
involvement it was kind of up down I
haven't seen Atlanta so I don't really
know too much about his output as a
creative force so I can't really judge
that one way or the other but I'm I'm
intrigued but I'm not I'm not jumping up
and down which you know as someone who
loves animation and loves comic books I
should I should be and yet I'm not so I
had to kind of pick apart as to why
wanted to share those thoughts with you
and I'm kind of feeling I'm going to get
called an idiot on this one and I'm
overdue for that I think it's been a
while since people have been calling me
an idiot on math so how much of an idiot
do you think I am whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast or the punch
like a girl podcasts both available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]